good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and happy Thursday hope everybody's
having a great day thus far hey ja how
you D I'm D good happy Thursday latter
half of the week gorgeous Tings gorgeous
Tings oh my
God gous tting gous
TS I can't go crosseyed but if I could
now would be the time one of my absolute
favorite things on the planet to do is
to like go crosseyed I think it's one of
my greatest talents I've recently
started incorporating it into my comedy
it's pure comedy it's pure comedy and as
a kid like I was told a thousand times
you're going to get stuck that way so I
used to be really afraid to do it then a
few years ago I was like wait I'm not
going to get stuck that way like what if
I
just you know yeah yeah I love it no I'm
I'm jealous that you have the I'm not
one of those people who has to like do
you know with the finger like no I'm
only do finger oranic literally part of
your comedic routine it's like adding a
curse word to a to a joke like it just
has gives it a little punch it gives an
extra M yeah so that's like another
thing you should we should add that to
your list because we're always like what
are your talents or what are my talents
like obviously you have the singing you
have I can go crosy natural Charisma
comedy she can go cross side yeah no I
adds a little spice you know yeah how
are you I'm good gu just Tings G just
Tings G just Tings gu just Tings G just
Tings how are you you how is do how is
our holistic king of acupuncture yes
Theo took a trip East yesterday actually
we went South it was downtown um and it
was good he got his first acupuncture
session he responded very well to it she
was like wow I wish all my patients were
like this he was so chill very Zen he is
Zen he is Zen embodied embodied yeah
what's the word embodied or personified
you you joined them together together
conjunction he bodified conjunction
Junction what's your
function um he did really well I she
said you know it's a journey you know
sometimes there are Miracles you know he
walks out of here perfect but you know
most of the time it takes a couple of
sessions and so we're going to do that
once a week you know radiation in the
beginning of the weeks acupuncture a few
days later seeing if one of these
Eastern or Western remedies are going to
you know help my boy hopefully it's East
vers West sharks vers Jets and the thing
is I would love to you know have this
you know one of them work and we can
definitively say which one it is and
then we can finally put to bed you know
is it East verse West that really works
but we won't know which one worked we're
just hoping one of them but perhaps if
it does work
bashem it would be a fusion of east and
west you know finally it's not about the
competition it's about the coming
together it would be North it would be
South it would be
Central South
Central east west
north south too no yeah
snow
news or SN really SN eat yeah Sno yeah
W's just a little
Compass fun for you today let's talk
about the compass app let's talk about
the compass in general as an invention
Compass or
Compass depends you
person comp it's personal potato potato
cuz you just said both in one sentence I
did yeah you said compass and then
Compass I guess it just depends on where
in the sentence it falls am I feeling
like enunciating in this part of the
sentence or not like with the word d a
TA I don't have a preferred anunciation
pronunciation it's just like I could use
it twice in the same day and use it
totally differently data data that's how
I feel about preference compass
compass compass yeah what were you going
to say about the compass as a an
invention the compass greater than it is
such an incredible invention I think it
it was one of those inventions that
really changed the world
industrialized you know one large leap
for mankind one small device for Man
true it's really a Marvel I know now we
just like look at the app on our phone
or our car tells us which way we're
facing but I think we take it for
granted yeah I I mean honestly like I
use directions I feel like most people
are like who needs a compass um North
South like it's not a big part of their
every day but in the city actually in
new YK City it is it is because there's
East Side West Side Uptown downtown
which is north south east and west and
when I'm in the city I actually at all
times really do know which way is North
which ways south which ways East and
which ways West which I feel like kind
of cool about yeah and if you don't you
get out your compass and then you know
exactly where you are yeah like I love
to you know be in a taxi and be like you
know it'll be Southeast Corner oh yeah I
am Lewis and Quark navigate clean yeah
yeah yeah no like when I pull those
words out that's like a like your driver
will know you're like a you're a New
Yorker yeah yeah like I think somebody
you know lesser than me would say oh the
far right corner but I would know that
that far right corner is actually the
southwest corner depending on where I'm
coming from yeah and also it's the far
right corner from the angle you're
coming at it from but it's the southwest
corner
universally so Lewis and Clark had
nothing on Jackson turd and Jackson turd
are the modern-day Lewis and Clark
trailblazing
Queens I would also say Jackson turd are
the modern day Bonnie and Clyde I would
say so too but we have a reverence for
the la la turd it's true it's true
except just trying to think
of the records from Yale about the three
identical strangers once we do steal
those Soul steal those sealed records
from Yale we will be the modern day
version of Bonnie but we won't be
driving away in a convertible we will be
driving away in a pickup truck that's us
or a Tesla or whatever we can get our
hands on at the Renta Center you know
yeah well I heard that you can rent a
Tesla at Herz now if you is that true
yeah if you've been wanting to try out
the experience that's actually like a
perfect thing to do when you're on
vacation like try a new car let me tell
you how one of my favorite things is
renting a car like the actual journey of
getting off the plane walking to the
rental waiting in line is torture when
you get a the keys and you're like
sometimes they let you choose from a
whole section of cars then you just get
to try out different cars that you're
never going to really have in your own
life like it's very exciting yeah I feel
like most of the times I've done rental
cars obviously I haven't rented a car
myself but you know with Zach or with
you always and wait Jackie why haven't
you rented a car yourself because I've
never had my license at a time when I
rented a car yeah and also it's just
like girls don't rent cars that's like a
thing for the husbands that's like such
a husband job to we us rent a car once
in a while and we flush the keys down
the toilet and now the Jaguar is still
sitting in Connecticut and you're never
going to be able to buy a home with your
credit oh my God I totally forgot
that moment I don't know how we could
talk about car rentals without talking
about the extremely Hasty vage and yes I
do often think about that car sitting in
that rest stop in Connecticut and I also
do get a pit every time I get like an
Experian email like a change in your
credit you know usually it's like your
credit limit coming back to haunt you
usually it's like little things like you
know your credit limit increased or you
know you spend more this month and you
didn't pay it down right right right but
one day it's just going to say there's
been a change in your credit
Jaguar yeah and if you don't know what
we're talking about it's such a long
Amazing Story and there's a whole
episode on it it's the episode is called
the extremely Hasty flush and you
absolutely need to listen to it it's a
cautionary tale for all drivers out
there rental car owners and people who
go to rest stops and if you're not going
to listen here's the lesson do not put
your rental car keys in your bra when
going to take a piss at a rest stop
especially a rest stop that has
automatic flushes Okay so we'll leave
you with that yeah where were we you
could rent a Herz I mean you couldent
Tesla when we're driving away with the
records because we're the modern day B
and Clyde Louis comp Compass we needed
to Center ourselves dirty
wait I wanted to say a few things from
yesterday's episode because a lot of
people had very good um responses to
like some of the things we had said the
first thing when we were talking about
Mark cubin there's a lot of conspiracy
theories now about Mark cubin a lot of
people think he might be running for
office okay um good luck with that good
luck with that Kenzie Elizabeth actually
text me because she's like a Dallas girl
and she listens to the
toast is it about the pharmaceutical
company yes so he talks about it on
Shark Tank a lot but his most recent
project I think is like his biggest
passion project where it's like a
website to get people medications for
like any and all diseases ailments at
like the cheapest possible right and
he's like a really passionate about it
like you know $16 for cancer drugs that
would normally cost $2,000 so it's very
expensive apparently he like very very
invested in it obviously financially but
also like emotionally and maybe he like
wanted to cash out to put that money
towards this particular project okay um
but then there was like another
conspiracy theory I saw going around on
Tik Tok that you know Dallas is like a
big Sports town but they don't have any
infrastructure yet for sports gambling
and casinos and I think there's like a
bunch of very wealthy people trying to
get that Initiative off the ground and
he might have sold to put money towards
that cuz that's going to be like a
billion multi-billion dollar journey and
interesting also is that the adelon
family like does casinos and resorts so
yes they are the Sands right so maybe
like their part in this has to do with
that too yeah and then I also heard that
this adelon fam had to cash out two
billion of their shares from sanss to
pay for the Mavs right so maybe they're
just like
moving the the their business down to
Dallas so it was a nice idea that he
wanted to you know spend time with his
family but I do think there's like a
business thing going on I don't think
he's running for office I don't think so
either I think the pharmaceutical thing
makes sense I hope he has success with
it someone needs to overhaul the
pharmaceutical system in this country
like it makes no sense no it's a
disgrace it's a disgrace like these are
life-saving medications like every like
all medication it's helping someone like
what is why is it like this no it's an
absolute disgrace and I agree if anyone
can do it I think it could be Mark Cuban
yeah I think so too good luck with that
yeah we truly wish you well if you need
to take a step back and ruin one of our
favorite shows then for this it's okay
but thankfully it's an ensemble show and
it is my personal belief that the show
won't be ruined without Mark me neither
the show will go on the other thing I
wanted to talk about somebody made such
an excellent point when we I didn't know
if people were going to agree with us or
the the sentiment of the weekend being
an industry plant was going to resonate
with people but it was just like this
feeling that I had and then you felt it
and I guess a lot of people felt it too
and somebody offered a really good
explanation for why he feels like
industry plant and they basically just
said like who goes to listen to the
weekend it's mostly just straight men
who don't really participate or
contribute to like Stan culture so they
don't have you know Twitter accounts
tracking all of the weekends charting
and everything they don't have fan
accounts they just listen and move on
with their lives and you know that is
powerful and obviously there's enough
people who do that but the reason why
we're not seeing that sort of perception
and and why it feels like a plant is
because they're not putting that energy
out there they don't participate in like
fan culture straight men they just enjoy
okay I agree with you except about the
fact that straight men don't participate
in fan culture the NFLs yeah Sports
nobody is more of a fan girly than those
guys that every weekend getting dressed
up in costume painting their faces
having a party like nuts n oh my God
okay there's NFL drama did you hear
about this it's
so yes it's a craziest thing okay let me
tell you so dead spin which is like this
website Sports publication Sports yeah
so they published an article about this
little kid who was at the Chiefs game
last weekend who was apparently wearing
black face and because they're the
Chiefs which is like Native American he
was wearing a big Native American
headdress so they had a picture of the
kid from the side you saw his whole he
must have been 8 years old he's nine not
oh wow okay his whole big headdress and
then his face is completely black and so
of course they like roasted this child
to
filth and it has come out recently I
mean it has come out since that article
came out they were using like a photo of
the kid where you only saw the side of
his face and if you saw him head on he
had half red half black which are the
chief's colors which is not black face
and this kid is Native American right
his grandfather was actually like a
really major like leader in the Chumash
tribe and if he wants to wear a Native
American headdress like he absolutely
can do that I just don't know why in the
first place like dead spin was going
after an 8-year-old what has the world
come to no it's so sick that story is
literally an accurate represent ation of
the media like they think they slay
let's you know skewer this 8-year-old
he's doing bad and then it's actually
not the whole picture literally
literally and it's like I'm sure none of
the people who worked on that article
have any ties to Native Americans
actually give a [__] about him wearing
the headdress but it's like actually he
does no it was such a crazy turn of
events I was like following the whole
thing on Tik Tok
um yeah context is key context is key
and then speaking of cancellations I'm
sure you have it as a story Gary no I
don't because I'm like kind of avoiding
all Gary Tings um yeah me too because
we're trying we're saving the golden
Bachelor for our family trip well by the
way predicted hold on I just I'm pretty
sure I need to correct this I'm pretty
sure it's pronounced Jerry but the
reason why we're confused is because we
thought it should be j e r r y like no
Jackie it's Gary no no no Claudia no I
remember when this happened like we did
a re about the golden Bachelor and we
were like and it's Jerry and then the
issue was We spelled it wrong in our
real it's supposed to be g e r r y oh so
people were saying it's spelled Jerry
not pronounced Gary yeah but we were
confused because it's like okay if it's
but if it's with the G then it's Gary
Jackie I just want to say and I don't
want to go looking for Clips because
you're right like we'll end up spoiling
it for herself I'm 95% sure it's Gary
both spelled and pronounced I think it's
spelled Gary pronounced Jerry well Gary
Jerry has been cancelled we literally
said like a year ago that he was going
to get canceled and I like we were
joking but it's so absurd because it
actually did happen you know apparently
all alleged you know his ex-wife who is
dead he said he wanted her to lose 10
PBS and she couldn't come to his high
school reunion unless she lost the 10
pounds and he started you know a a new
relationship one month after she died
like okay and whose [__] business is
that and who what if he started dating
someone a month after how do we know he
told his ex-wife to lose 10bs cuz she
came back from the dead and told the New
York Post for real for real no I didn't
read the article I only read the
headlines because I don't want to spoil
it but like I can't believe we're trying
to cancel
this geriatric this
geriatric
literally he likes a spelt woman no but
like okay you're kidding me right like
this is so I first of all I'm going to
need proof and second of all like I'm
just I don't know like I
it's I'm just not cancelling the the
oldest man on the planet like I'm just
not I'm not canceling the golden
Bachelor no it's I can't I can't it's
it's actually s when there's so many
cancel worthy things happening right now
and very few cancellations so Gary I'm
not going to waste my breath on doesn't
even make my list of 1,000 no it's so
true like let the man be fat phobic in
peace okay but it's also has been proven
that he's even fat phobic no I know and
be allegedly fat phobic in peace no it's
so true like how do we know that these
conversations took place when one of the
people is dead and the other is Gary
He's not going to tell the New York Post
okay but I did see a headline I didn't
click on it but now that you're
mentioning it that he told it was an
ex-girlfriend that he told to lose 10
pound and she might be living but I did
that's my putting well she sounds like a
scorned lover for sure you can't take
her
seriously okay The Hollywood Reporter
the golden Bachelor not so golden
past okay let's get into it let's get
into it by sharp contrast to the young
cads with six-pack abs previous okay I
don't need like their their
editorialization and and word count so
that you can hit as many advertisers as
possible still grieving a widower oh
Gary pronounced Gary oh it's like Gary g
a r y it's pronounced g a i r y so
you're adding a third pronunciation to
the mix Hollywood Reporter is not me
cried real tears during the opening
episode when he recounted the story of
Tony his beloved wife of 43 years who
tragically died of of an infection just
one month after their moved to their
dream retirement house in Hudson Indiana
it was a dramatic backstory but our
Bachelor was able to switch gears and
interact easily with the attractive and
equally senior okay I don't want to see
hold on let me just find
yeah you might have to go to a different
publication that like doesn't take
itself so seriously and just gives you
the tea so he had told Entertainment
Tonight that he hadn't dated in 45 years
because he was married for 43 oh I was
like okay that makes
sense despite despite the vetting The
Hollywood Reporter has discovered
several inconsistencies oh no regarding
both his work history oh yeah oh my God
I read I saw this on Tik Tok they're
literally dragging him like for his
LinkedIn okay regarding both his work
history we did that yesterday to the
poet shut
up they they found inconsistencies
regarding both his work history and
recent romantic entanglements that
contradict the received narrative
whether they never learned about these
discrepancies ABC or ignored them to
sell a buffed up shinier storyline for
the greater impact producers presented
an incomplete and misleading image of
Turner which The Bachelor helped
perpetuate in personal remarks but it
was just a buffed up story to make him
like I think they called him a
restaurant tour to accentuate his impact
no that's what they said listen it's
it's Show Business Baby a buffed up
story to accentuate his impact I can
live with he's identified in Chiron
throughout the show as a retired
restaurant tour which is a fancy way to
say he owns or owned a restaurant with
all of its attendant fun and glamour but
according to his profile on
LinkedIn Gary last owned a restaurant
in8 1985 when he sold his Mr Quick
hamburger Drive-In franchise in Iowa
Iowa where he worked his way up from
high school well that's impressive right
after that he held various sales and
management positions in the meat
business again per his LinkedIn resume
which does not list an end date for his
employment this does not match up with
the idea that was pushed on the show
that he retired at the young age of 55
which would have been 2006 never
mentioned are his years of pickup
post-retirement work like installing hot
tubs at Ganon pools near Davenport Iowa
he then worked as a maintenance man this
is so elst he's cancelled because he
didn't disclose he was installing hot
tubs he then worked as a maintenance man
at the Vera French Mental Health Center
also in the Davenport area as ver by his
colleagues who spoke highly of him hard
so entitled yeah of course first of all
he worked at a burger joint in high
school years later he worked his way up
to being the owner of that franchise
sold it and then did it rest on his
Laurels and got more jobs no job too big
or too small for him this is a dream man
yeah so I guess who The Hollywood
Reporter is upset that like maybe the
bachelor just kind of condensed the
story he owned restaurants he sold and
and retired but okay where 's the crime
so then he came to know a woman they're
calling her Carolyn with whom he would
go on to have a nearly three-year
relationship with beginning innocently
enough a month after his wife's death
attractive and 14 years as Junior she
was a staff accountant at the mental
health center they dated for 10 months
and then lived together for a year and
nine months this account is drawn from
interviews with Carolyn who requested
not to be named to protect her privacy
as well as friends she confided in at
the time and text messages with Gary
among other documents so wait say they
they dated for 10 months after after
they dated for 10 months and they lived
together for a year and nine months so
almost two years they were only dating
for 10 of those months no no no the
total they were together for 3 years 10
months dating not living together a
month a year and nine months living
together so three years almost okay but
not three years because they met they
knew each other for 3 years but like
they're that's intentionally misleading
because they met a month after his wife
died but they didn't start dating until
a few months later if you count all
those months up okay so they were in
some sort of entanglement for nearly 3
years nearly three years but not
starting a month after the wife died no
they met actually it says beginning
innocently enough a month after his wife
means I met you at work and I know you
the fact that he started dating is not
unexpected he was single and a widower
after all not cheating but his Amorous
activity certainly didn't align with how
he regularly yanked viewers heartstrings
with on air announcement about his lack
of a love life since his wife died he
later touchingly admitted to one
pre-show kiss on The Bachelor Happy Hour
podcast okay so they're coming for him
because he was with this girl for three
years but he said on the show like he
hasn't known true love it seems like it
was just a situationship and she's
getting caught up like yeah no like she
thought it was more than it was so this
relationship with Carolyn is not the
only relationship the golden Bachelor
and Jerry produced to producers fail to
mention this fall a reporter from the US
son reached out to Heather a waitress at
the Shady Nook a bar and restaurant
located on the lake in Hudson Indiana
next door to Gary's new lake house so
close that he'd essentially made it his
Bachelor clubhous why did the sun reach
out to Heather right Heather who no
longer works there considered Gary her
friend she told the reporter that in the
past six years he dated a couple of
women they weren't all longterm but they
weren't short-term either he was with a
couple of women for a decent amount of
time but it just didn't work out well
what's a decent amount of time uh okay
so let's say he dated a couple so the
fact that they didn't include it on the
show makes these people like liars it's
TV no but these articles are
intentionally vague not for a long time
not for a short time everybody has a
different idea of what a decent amount
of time for a relationship is like also
he said he hasn't had love since his
wife passed so okay he didn't love these
women sorry girls like no and a lot of
people at that age just date for um
companionship this is so sick wait
Carolyn the first girl for 3 years
didn't want the years of her life as the
golden bachelor's girlfriend to become a
national news father but neither did she
she want to be the Invisible Woman
whispered about in Davenport as the
gullible gal Gary dumped duped and then
dumped so Susan mccre who's a close
friend of Carolyn it's giving Karen
mclusky is what it's giving I just can't
believe this happened to my girlfriend
she said when Caroline and Gary first
started dating in September 2017 my
husband and I took them to an Iowa
Hawkeyes football game I thought this
guy's legit this guy's a really good guy
for her mccre recalled watching the show
and hearing Gary say that line about not
having been having been kissed for 6
years and I'm like what he's got to know
what people that people are paying
attention to the show I'm just
flabbergasted at first Carolyn tried to
laugh it off but then the golden
Bachelor became a ratings Bonanza the
show was suddenly the talk of Pop
Culture considered a breakthrough for
its positive portrayal of sexually
active seniors and it bothered Carolyn
that her ex was foisting lines and
moving on to the bachelorettees that he
had used to seduce her I just want to
say she was surprised that the show was
a success it's the bachelor so he he had
texted Carolyn on September 2nd 2017
Less Than 3 months now they're saying 3
months after Tony's death his wife he
says damn I go to bed at night thinking
of you and wake up in the morning
thinking of you that's so sweet that's
literally so sweet so because he sent
that text he's not allowed to break up
with her no it's insane I guess the one
lie I'm really detecting is he said he
hadn't been kissed in six years and and
there were kisses that happened okay has
anybody watch the show unreal do you
know how much Bachelor producers
manipulate everything there's other
women in here I'm not in the mood to
read this entire article you would think
that like honestly grown women would not
be acting this way like I expect it when
like you know Jed's exgirl girlfriend is
actually his girlfriend and she comes
forward was his girlfriend he's on the
show but like Ken mclusky is in her 50s
and like you really want to drag Gary
now the man's like just trying to find
love and set like a a nice uh realistic
expectation for seniors in Love no it's
so absurdly stupid I can't get over it
that's honestly The Hollywood Reporter
should be ashamed of themselves everyone
should be ashamed and it's like they dug
this deep and this was the worst that
they came up with Gary's probably an
amazing guy I agree I hope Gary just
lets this roll off his back I don't know
the it's it's hard actually but he's old
he's old hopefully he's wise and he
knows it doesn't matter and he can
ignore the noise insane we stand with
you Gary yeah that's crazy is it really
like actually canceling him or it's just
like tryina I don't think anybody cares
like it's hard to cancel someone who's
60 and like probably just made an
Instagram and and a Twitter like he's
like okay so I'll leave yeah oh okay
I'll just not
post yeah and as stated he has plenty of
jobs and skills and he doesn't need the
Internet no that like work thing really
bothered me yeah like it was very
judgmental and elitist like he installed
hot tubs and and what and what about it
so no I guess the point just to be you
know Devils at Advocate it's like he
said he retired at 55 but he's still
working this these people are disgusting
like seriously we're clowning on someone
for you know living the American dream
jealous and it's like why are you
digging on Gary why yeah what did he do
to you it's bad faith bad faith actors
1,000% being badly faithful to their bad
faith and acting while doing it in
nefarious manner so dumb so dumb
well I'm glad that we parsed through
that and I can go into the holiday
watching golden Bachelor feeling proud
of my support for Gary and his hot tub
Dreams And Trades his hot tub
dreams his hot tub dreams and I'm sure
there's going to be some hot tubs on the
show and I just have to say like leave
Gary alone leave Gary alone this is why
we can't have nice things seriously true
the bachor tried to do something nice
and pure and they distilled his story
down to something you know just so
palatable fairy tale we don't have all
the time in the world on television no
that's the point of the bachelor it's
like everyone who's a lead is a loser
and they try and make them look cool and
successful like that's the whole premise
of the show literally like they have to
make it so that like he's desirable for
25 women right it's a show like get a
grip it's Show Business Baby should we
dive in if you can't handle it don't
watch yes I think we shall dive in
because that was like a six Man story
yeah without further ad do to do too
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know and the fast five stories
that you need to know are brought to you
by DraftKings Casino step into a world
of non-stop action on DraftKings Casino
play the classics like Blackjack
roulette and Slots plus enjoy exclusive
games you can't find anywhere else all
you have to do is sign up select the
offer make your deposit and start
playing from a full Suite of games it's
such a blast download the draft C King
casino app now and sign up with promo
code the toast new customers can get a
deposit match up to $500 in Casino
credits when you deposit $5 or more only
on DraftKings casino with promo code the
toast gambling problem call A 1 1800
Gambler or visit 1 www.1 1800 gambler.
net in Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call 8887895118
physically physically present in
Connecticut Michigan New Jersey
Pennsylvania West Virginia only void and
Ontario only opted one per opted in new
customer minimum $5 deposit Max match
500 in Casino credits which require 1X
play through within 7 Days C terms
casino. draftkings.com players choice
for eligibility terms and responsible
gaming s resources today's episode is
also brought to you by Squarespace the
all-in-one website platform for
entrepreneurs to stand out and succeed
online whether you're just starting out
or managing a growing brand Squarespace
makes it easy to create a beautiful
website engage with your audience and
sell anything from products to content
to time all in one place all on your
terms so whatever your reasoning may be
for wanting to start a website the best
place to go is Squarespace they're going
to do it all for you top to bottom
whatever you might need a website for
whether you're getting into e-commerce
you have a side business you want to
display your work you're an artist of
some sorts perhaps a poet like Casey
musk Graves ex-boyfriend um they have
amazing product features for whatever
your needs are you can sell custom merch
which will create passive income it'll
also engage your audience of course you
can create an online store with
Squarespace where you can sell your
products online then they also have a
point of sale so if you're selling
online but you want to sell in person at
like a trade show or something you can
sell in person by connecting a square
reader to the Squarespace app then
you'll keep all your orders inventory
and customer data in sync with your
online store so it's just really
organized and really easy they have
super flexible website templates you can
get started with one of their
professional templates with designs for
every category and use case and then
customize your look update your content
and add features to fit your unique
unique needs Head to squarespace.com for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com
toast that way you'll save 10% off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
that's squarespace.com
when you're ready to launch your website
and you'll get 10% off of your first
purchase of a website or a domain
today's episode is also brought to you
by Wella well professionals has over 140
years of experience developed developed
initially for professional use only and
previously only has been sold in salons
and it's consistently ranked among the
top loved Brands by professional stylist
but the Wella professionals new line the
ultimate repair line is the most premium
line to date it was developed by 100
with 140 years of experience and
research to deliver the very best and
now you can get your hands on it the
miracle hair rescue repairs hair in only
90 seconds so ultimate repairs Miracle
Hair rescue is a leave-in spray
treatment designed to work on wet hair
if you have um used a lot of heat on
your hair and you're always always
wanting to make sure you're using the
right products before using heat I love
the Wella ultimate repair Miracle Hair
Rescue It smells so good I'm like so
into products that smell good cuz now
when I work out I'm just like so nervous
about my scalp smelling it smells so
good you spray it on your wet hair
before you start styling let I use like
10 pumps you know coat generously and
then just let it sit for at least 90
seconds and then you can style as
normally your hair will look shiny and
healthy I really love the product it has
Rich textures and floral scents and it
is designed for all hair types and
textures it is a perfect l
leave-in spot treatment and everyone can
benefit from it you can try the ultimate
Miracle repair Miracle Hair rescue with
uh 10% off so if you go on Amazon it's
the ultimate repair Miracle Hair rescue
from Wella you can get 10% off on Amazon
of the travel size by using promo code
tenent toast that's one t o a s
t ultimate repair Miracle Hair rescue
10% off with that code I love that it's
just easy to apply you can leave it in
all day it's safe on on colored hair it
can be applied right after you towel dry
your hair it's easy it's fabulous it's
just a great thing to add to your
routine thanks La you're welcome fa our
first story and move that will surprise
no one Courtney Kardashian in ingests
her juicy placenta after her son Rocky's
birth you this Courtney posted on her
Instagram her mommy made encapsulation
placenta pills which she showed was her
juicy placenta and she talked about a
lot of the benefits of eating your
placenta and I would like to discuss
with my sister-in-law turd our thoughts
on this so here are some of the benefits
she said that people report higher
energy levels lesser chance of baby
blues lesser chance of postpartum
depression balanced mood and hormones
increased milk supply tempting enhance
bonding experience with baby higher iron
levels reduce postnatal bleeding uterus
returning back to pre- pregancy size
faster losing the baby weight faster
tempting and overall faster and better
recovery from having the baby so it was
not an ad she just wanted to share I
mean if anybody on the planet is going
to eat their placenta like it is going
to be Courtney Kardashian so this is it
would be more surprising if she wasn't
doing this cuz a lot of people even like
nons super crunchy people do it um and I
just want to get your thoughts like do
you think that you would be eating your
placenta honestly I'm not entirely
against it like I have known that people
do this for a while and when I first
heard it I knew that people did it
primarily to combat combat postpartum
depression so like anything you can do
sure but I have also and I'm sure
Courtney got like the best of the best
but a lot of these companies that did
you do a capsule they put it in like a
pill yes like a lot of the times that
process strips your placenta of all its
nutrients by the time you get it in that
capsule interesting I've also read on
the contrary side that like the function
of the placenta is kind of to like
filter out like toxic things in your
body like so that they don't make its
way to the baby cuz it it's like the
conduit between you and on your baby so
it's kind of like all the things that
your baby didn't get for a reason oh
that's interesting for sure like if
there if there was like a definitive
answer like yes it's good for you or bad
it's no for you like I would do it yeah
you wouldn't be icked out no I'm not
going to sit down with a fork and a
knife and start cutting it like that the
thing is I feel like if you want to eat
your placenta like you actually have to
take a bite out of it like these P I
know people do it in like a shake where
like they'll literally put chunks of
placenta with like chunks it's not pills
no no no like like more raw okay cuz I
feel like if you're going to do it you
got to go
raw yeah yeah I want fork and knife it's
literally that scene in Game of Thrones
where Daenerys like eats that heart
yeah
yeah and this reminds me of the episode
of the Kardashians where they pranked
everyone into thinking that they ate a
placenta yeah I'm actually surprised
that Courtney pills hers and doesn't
just like go straight from the source
right but I have to imagine like she's
so Health girly she probably did
extensive research yeah I think also the
thing with this it's like it could have
all these benefits if it if it does what
it you think it's going to do or worst
case scenario like it doesn't do much
but it might make you feel better me
it's like a placebo placenta like really
what placeo for sure unless it's like
the downside is the thing that you you
just said right but that's not proven
either like there's not too much actual
information it's you know what Courtney
said is some of the benefits people
report that's not like proven benefit
it's just like how I
feel I'm not against it like it's
obviously sounds crazy and gross but
like it kind of makes sense
yeah yeah I wonder if they ate their
placentas back in the day like when did
this start and where did we get the idea
I guess other animals I think we're the
only mammals that don't eat their
placentas naturally oh so we're just
like copying like our our mammal friends
M the mammals it's good enough for the
mammals it's good enough for me right I
mean we're all one in the same yeah I'm
not entirely against this and I think a
lot of people like probably would assume
that I would be and like drag people cuz
it's like gross but no whatever the
masas need to do to be okay like I don't
care yes
placentophagia that's I guess what it's
called is a behavior present in almost
all female terrestrial etherian mammals
more than 4,000 species consisting of
the ingestion of the placenta H the more
you know but then three articles down no
you shouldn't eat your placenta here's
why well I don't know these are the same
people who are writing about Gary from
Indiana so I don't know who to trust
anymore I don't know I don't
know is eating the placenta beneficial
to date there's no evidence from Human
studies to support these claims you
could say that about anything I know
it's just it's a personal preference
it's a personal
preference Kim ate her placenta too oh I
wouldn't say that for her right hm the
placenta is just kind of this just
transcends
everything yeah it does and it's you
know more personal than comedy more
personal than did you have to push out
your placenta or it was just like uh
yeah it's like came out well no no no
you have to the doctor has to take it
out and either they press on on your
belly I wasn't paying attention it's
it's nothing compared toing birth like
yeah they can really like press it out
or maybe you give like one more push but
nothing of no
interesting and then it's gone it's big
really like the size of the
baby yeah uh maybe like in width yeah
it's like a nice big big what like piece
of meat honestly like when we did the
brisket when we cooked the brisket that
you have to ruin the brisket for me that
looks like a
placenta wow and then what do they do
with it if you don't want it they send
it for
testing oh I'm pretty sure I wonder if
they do that yeah I'm pretty sure they
do that for every one they send it for
testing but if you want to eat it you
have to wait for the testing yeah I
think you uh fill out a form to get it
back I don't
know honestly yeah of course of course
yeah and then you have to get it to the
place and it's like is it on ice the
whole time right that's what I was
saying about the capsules like by the
time you actually get it into powder
capsules what's the point what happens
to your
placenta actually this conversation is
making me like a little nauseous
really yeah it's beautiful no
like you can discard it in which case
your hospital or birthing center will
take care of this that's kind of sad you
could take your placenta
home and in some places people bury
their
prenta it's so fascinating beyond the
placenta is more personal than comedy
more personal than that's true that's
true so glad Courtney's eating hers me
too I'll make you placenta pills as your
push present thanks I'd prefer like a
diamond necklace but go off a placenta
necklace ew our next story Christen
cavalary reveals the hottest guy she's
ever hooked up
with do you want to take a guest before
I share with you Jay Cutler no that
would be so nice if she said that Tyler
Cameron but I oh yeah she said Cameron
and believe it or not you guys I know
this is really freaking hard to believe
he's hotter in person she said it's
insane so what do people be these days
when they say hookup they okay I don't
think so they're kind of they never had
a relationship he was in her campaign
for she used him and paid him for
publicity right but they did like kiss
in the ad so yeah maybe that was the
hookup but then also like there was like
a video of them like dancing sexily at a
party so I don't know if they like
hooked up offline but she has maintained
that they never like had any sort of
relationship yeah no that was clear
um no like Tyler Cameron is the hottest
man alive and he's literally could not
be a nicer person and is so lovely and
it makes him hotter yeah he should be
people sexiest man alive because like
that's really what he is he's
actually by definition sexy yeah that's
actually an amazing point he really
should be
yeah
SE what nothing oh actually this just
reminded me I went out to dinner last
night and there was a man in the
restaurant who was so beautiful like it
was shocking how
old my age like nothing like maybe a
little bit older how would you feel if
your father was dating someone your age
and he was wearing this just like you
know beige Kashmere sweater he was just
so well dressed well quaffed he had this
like beautiful blonde hair and like
honestly like everyone in the restaurant
was looking at him he was he was
otherworldly like he was so beautiful
where did you go to dinner I when I
decided I wanted to share this story on
the toast as I walked to work this
morning I knew you were going to ask me
that and I think I should not say
because like his sister is probably a
toaster like I don't need that sort of
oh the the man but why I didn't know you
went to dinner last night yeah I we
literally spoke on the
phone and I said I just got back from
dinner I didn't hear that who' you go to
dinner with
my friends from
college your friends from college aren't
those your friends from high school well
something Shady about this dinner lck oh
no no no no I was I actually don't know
how to describe him because I met with
Abe who's my best friend from like high
school but then also Margo fish who's my
friend from college but me Abe and Margo
became like a threesome in college so I
think describing them as my friends from
college is accurate okay technically but
then also Margo fish became a part of
your high school group of friends like
yes yes get together with your high
school friend she's there she's there
but I know Margo from college that was
so crazy yeah oh there's another
conspiracy kind of going around in the
toast stum I don't know if you've SE I
don't know if you've seen it because it
has to do with me but you cut me off the
other day when I was about to say a
story of something that happened in
college I like oh yeah I started to say
it twice and I got cut off both times
and then I just like gave up what was
the story everyone wants to know the
story okay you said a conspiracy theory
about me no no I said about me oh okay
okay I said about the like the toes
there's like okay okay people like were
petitioning to hear the story it's like
not this when you fell off your bike no
no no we were talking about brainy
quotes you falling off your bike is the
best story when you fell sorry sorry sh
Claudia doesn't want to hear my brainy
quotes College story oh [__] yeah yeah
yeah okay go but it's not even that
great of a story which is kind of why I
gave up trying to say it like it's
really not that great but I feel like
any story that starts with like in
college one time you think it's going to
be really great but I'll just I'll let
you know so there was um someone who
wrote uh his paper and I don't know
where he left it somewhere and you know
how sometimes you would start a paper
with a quote Oh it's like the laziest
move ever yeah it's like really profound
way to start a paper like a quote that
kind of encapsulates what you're about
to talk about gets the reader inspired
Albert Einstein once said yeah no or
it's just like speak strong and carry a
big stick
yeah and then you get into you know
policy anyway so we found some's paper
and the top of the paper had a quote and
he had his uh citation when he went to
the citation at the bottom it was brainy
quotes.com
that's a story that's a it was just an
anecdote about brainy quotes yeah yeah
yeah and like is brainy quote a
legitimate site Source you can say well
that's just like not where the quote
originated from right right and do you
have to
Source a quote let me just tell you like
bibliography culture is you do have to
Source a quote otherwise you could just
be making up quotes yeah yeah
yeah I was never into
bibliographies
no I I'm into sourcing but I'm not into
bibliography format no yeah I just
wanted my bibliography to write like
trust me you know yeah no like I just
want to be able to like bullet points
like here's where I was looking at you
know go find it yourself not like MLS
the quotations MLS Chicago like the
quotations the commas the
underlines so true sickening why did we
need to learn that I don't know but now
it's like I kind of wish people were
learning bibliographies instead of the
poison they are learning you know y yep
let's go back to the
MLS let's go back to MLM okay things
were so simple when we were all just
selling
leggings let's go back to
MLM take me back some people are still
there yeah good for them I love I love
the girlies on Tik Tok like who cannot
be deterred like mlms could not have a
worse reputation like I feel like these
days like if you join an MLM there's
enough information for you out there for
like you to be turned off to it and so
if you're so Resolute in your desire to
sell makeup or whatever like I have such
respect for people just like doing the
opposite of what everyone's telling them
to do agreed but then how do you feel
about those people when it doesn't work
out like being like I'm a vitim yeah I
don't know I haven't thought through my
whole I don't have like a fully thought
out thesis on at this point if you open
eyes enter into an MLM right what
happens next For Better or For Worse you
are responsible for right no but that's
also like now if you were to literally
just like walk by Scientology and and go
in how do you not know
right right you're grown adults take
responsibility for the choices that you
make especially when there's ample
information out
there that's all we can do as girl
adults 100% our next Story Christmas is
heating
up by the way I watched a Christmas tree
lighting last night Kelly hosted a
two-hour live special where she's sang
like five times on finally she's getting
to work at being our America sweetheart
it was incredible it was so well done
first of all David Foster and Katherine
MC saying everybody just saying the
classics they're kind of the new faces
of Christmas don't they were she was
spectacular is Kiki Palmer Kiki Palmer
saying um what did she say like they all
sound the same jingle bell something
like that no Katherine MC did Jingle
Bells and I don't remember what um maybe
I'll Be Home for
Christmas she was
impeccable Liz Gillies and Seth
McFarland did a duet adorable they love
Christmas as well the night ended with a
duet of share and Darlene
Love it was breathtaking like it really
was and then Kelly of course did a few
of her originals and then they lit the
tree it was stunning beautiful you would
never know you didn't see on TV like all
the chaos that ensued at the that there
like people yeah animals came and like
like the Hamas protesters yeah I mean
they did but I guess it didn't make it
to TV no it didn't make it to TV and
then after that was Christmas at
Graceland hosted by Laney Wilson where
they had Lana Del R Casey Musgraves Lany
Wilson a bunch of people performing I
fell asleep but I did do wish I recorded
it it was really beautiful and they
literally set up like little stages
inside of graceand I'm sure it be on
Hulu or whichever streamer affiliated
with the network peacock it was like a
gorgeous night of programming at NBC
they crushed it wow that's great yeah
Santa can't you hear me well now is some
Christmas programming not NBC um
lifetime has its first ever Christmas
movie with a sex
scene oh my God and guess who's starring
in it Gretchen wers no but I feel like
you could guess I don't think you will
but if you want if we sat here long
enough I feel like you could okay give
me like three Clues okay she is an
actress I would hope so she's an
influencer she's a
podcaster Becca
toin no but that's a great
guess she's a podcaster influencer and
actress yeah actress first okay and then
but now I would say I
know Jan Kramer Janna Kramer stars in
lifetime's First Christmas movie with a
sex scene more like trip XX Miss Janna
Kramer's upcoming Lifetime movie A
Cowboy Christmas romance is the
Network's first movie with a sex scene
so she was actually pregnant while
filming the movie and she said it's on
her podcast she said it's the first
lifetime Christmas movie that has a sex
scene when I read it I was like well
this is going to be interesting I'm like
how are we going to do this with a baby
the movie portrays Lexi khaw a real
estate closer who returns to her
hometown of tuac Arizona to try to
convince Kobe Mason a horse whipping
Rancher to get I think you're going to
say a [__] to give up his family's land
while also reconsidering returning home
to her Roots about the steamy scene she
said we're on this spoiler alert he lays
me down on some hay and then and then we
you know and then you know obviously
it's still lifetime it's still family
but it was pushing limits there too I do
feel like lifetime got so
surpassed by Hallmark in the Christmas
category that this is an attempt to you
know just do to one up the most yeah but
the thing is with these types of
films the whole point of them and why
they're so different and weird and why
people are drawn to them is because
they're like so
conservative that like the formula is so
bizarre but it weirdly works it's just
like these almost like these like dumb
made for TV movies that have so much
heart and they like don't make a lot of
sense but they're really well done and I
think this might complicate that
formula well I think lifetime does need
to find a way to differentiate himself
because there is Lifetime Christmas
movies there's Hallmark there is Netflix
like who everyone's making Christmas
movies they're all following the hallmar
template but I I commend lifetime for
literally stepping their [__] up they
did step their literal [__] up we're
going to do Christmas different like if
you want a little smut with your
Christmas jolly good fun come over to
Lifetime I think that they're offering
something new and different and and that
might resonate with viewers no but it's
still on cable so like they're really
they're not going to be doing like G of
Thrones Vibes no it's going to be soft
right maybe if they did do like hardcore
smut Christmas on maybe on their app or
something that would be powerful that's
the title a hardcore smut
Christmas no the title of my Christmas
smut movie would
be got
it Christmas is
coming that's good Christmas is coming
and so am I I was singing jingle balls
oh love that too but it's not mine's a
little bit more subtle
or this isn't a title we could work
through it Workshop yeah something about
like a ho ho ho Christmas so I was
thinking like I my when I was going to
say if you read it it doesn't sound bad
it was more like my intonation like
Holly Jolly Christmas
you say it like that everything is good
yeah right Santa Claus is coming to town
right or
like Deck the Halls Deck the balls deck
the ball this is a JRE that's right for
exploration it's so true get to work I
think Janna's the woman to do it
lifetime nwork for it Jan's like a a
God-fearing woman like but she was in
entourage and she was a very promiscuous
college student
H
yeah no I think I think this is a really
good like first step for lifetime I
think they're the right Network I think
they got the right girl this story looks
like a beautiful love
story about a horse whipping Rancher I
know I've told the story a thousand
times but I can't talk about lifetime
Christmas movies without talking about
the one I saw with my biic no you
literally can't what was that I I was on
tour and there was like one channel on
the TV so I watched this lifetime
Christmas movie it was like Han it was a
Hanukkah movie and that's why you like
don't like when they do Hanukkah movies
and I just don't like when they do
Hanukkah movies period like like we
don't not everything has to be like for
like it's about the Christmas movies no
it's so true like the Hanukkah movie it
was so bad it was bad it's it's always
bad and like representation is nice but
like the non-jews can have Christmas
it's okay with me yeah they can have
their holiday movies like it's fine it's
fine yeah that's your Mii alic story
yeah yeah I'm so glad I was able to
bring that up today thanks for choosing
that story it's been bursting all year
long yeah are you ready for our next
story if it's our next story that's
brought to you by State Farm the State
Farm personal price plan helps you
create an affordable price just for you
the plan is all about being personal to
you and to your needs so that means
you're getting the coverage you want a
policy that helps cover what's important
to you and an affordable price just for
you because after after all life is just
better when you can personalize your
experiences so think about it like this
from your go-to coffee order to your
favorite pair of sweatpants we know that
you love to personalize your entire day
just like we do you know when it comes
to food Jackie and I are so different
she loves a breakfast taco personally
it's just not my thing but Jackie just
kind of is obsessed with them like
endlessly she would have them every day
if she could um and we're so different
like that and insurance you have
something to say I mean I only have a
breakfast taco when I come to New York
cuz it's next to the studio I heard a
rumor from Julia that you actually eat
three a day when I'm not there oh I mean
this is common everyone's constantly
spreading rumors about me my Dorman said
I was pregnant yesterday there's just
don't believe everything you read Jacks
clearly personalization makes everything
better and State Farm believes that
insurance should work the same way your
plan your coverage and your selections
can all be personalized to
you like a good
neighbor St f is there
prices vary by state options selected by
customer availability and eligibility
may vary ja hit me like a good neighb
State Farm is there today's episode is
also brought to you by Blue Nile we've
never heard anyone complain about
receiving jewelry as a present I think
we can all agree it's the premium gift
but it can be tricky to get the gift
right and when you're investing in a
piece for yourself or for anyone else
you want to make sure that everything
about it is absolutely perfect and
that's why we want to share what makes
us feel the best about a jewelry
purchase and that's when we Source it
from Blue nile.com Blue Nile offers
thousands of independently graded
diamonds and fine jewelry at prices
significantly below traditional retail
whether you're looking for a bit of
Summer Sparkle for yourself or a gift
for someone special Blue Nile offers
peace of mind with every purchase with
some of the highest quality standards in
the industry you can design your own
earrings for something custom and fresh
or you can check out their necklaces for
a Timeless essential the process of
shopping on Blue Nile is just fun and
easy and it's different and I really
like that that their um pieces are made
with the highest quality and they have
really high standard but it's also
reasonable and a not affordable but you
know reasonably priced for what you're
getting it's high quality stuff it's
premium stuff the things that we've
gotten from Blue Nile are gorgeous
beautiful if you have questions blue
Nile's jewelry experts are on hand 24/7
via phone or chat from Tech questions to
budget suggestions they're here to help
you find a gift that you can feel good
about Blue Nile also offers 30day
returns and a diamond price match
guarantee so you can always rest easy
knowing that you've made the right
choice experience the ease and
convenience of shopping Blue Nile today
at Blue nile.com that's blue
n.com thank you la you're welcome our
next story Elon Musk tells advertisers
who left x quote go [__]
yourself Elon Musk the CEO of Tesla and
SpaceX and the owner of X formerly
Twitter sends says that the current
Advertiser boycott could kill the
company so he was interviewed by Andrew
Ross sorin on Wednesday afternoon at the
New York Times deal book summer and he
is making headlines waves the clip was
everywhere the clip was everywhere so
the interviewer asked him like what
about advertisers leaving the platform
and why are advertisers leaving the
platform advertisers are leaving the
platform because of that thing that he
tweeted like a week or two ago about the
he responded to a tweet about Jewish
communities which I want to talk about
that initial tweet people are saying
that like it was anti-semitic what he
said okay he later clarified so he had
quote tweeted a tweet that said like uh
something calling out like Jewish
communities and how they've kind of all
bought into like these Progressive ideas
that are now being wielded against them
and and Elon responded this is the
actual truth now the Tweet itself was
clumsy because it said it made it seem
like all Jews right all Jews are
progressive and into that stuff and also
that like all progressives are Jews
which is just not true and Elon had
since clarified like that's not what he
meant um and so but El also just got
back from a trip from Israel like
I to call someone anti-semitic because
of a tweet when they literally just got
back from Israel and visited the K
booots and visited with families like
I'm sorry that is that's more important
and more indicative of anything right
and the interviewer had started the
question I think he was trying to say
like was that press were kind of like
just to make up for that tweet like to
smooth it over like does this person
know Elon has he ever like done anything
to appease anyone when he says something
that he believes he like immediately
clarified that he was talking specific
Jewish groups like The ADL which by the
way like it's true and it's like kind of
a reckoning going on in the Jewish
Community right now of like how the
progressive cause has completely left us
out and a lot of progressive Jews are
like what the [__] they don't know they
don't know where to turn it's been like
a it's been a lot of Jews who are
extremely Progressive and identify so
much of their identity is rooted in that
progressivism are having like identity
crisis now and they really don't know
where to turn because you know when
you've devoted so much of your identity
to standing up for what you believe and
then nobody stands up for you you're
like well what the [__] how do we get
here how do we get out right also
speaking of your girl my biic did a
video talking about this did you see her
video it was a few weeks ago okay what'd
she say um how she's just like left
heartbroken by all of like her Pro like
she thought that she was a part of this
movement and she was marching with this
group and that group and this group and
that group and like she's been
completely left out of it and she's kind
of you know coming to that realization
you should watch that video to
understand like what's kind of going on
I think a lot of people have seen that
video anyway so that's just kind of what
Elon was saying when people like were
like this is anti-Semitic he's like I'm
talking about like specific Jewish
groups not the entire Jewish community
and then so Advertiser and then also it
was kind of like a Media Matters it's a
campaign against him to slander his him
as an anti-semite and take him out for
that but like he's not an anti-semite I
don't believe him to be an anti-semite I
really don't not at all he then went to
Israel I don't think it was to appease
anyone cuz as it's clear he doesn't do
that he literally told advertisers to go
[__] themselves what he said he doesn't
do that but also like taking a 13-hour
trip to a war zone is not something you
do to appease people you do it because
you think it's the right thing to do
right no if you want to appease people
you make a donation you make a stat or
right you educate yourself and listen
and learn um no but he went to Israel he
met with hostage families he met with
victim families like he's wearing a dog
tag with victim's name on it who said he
said he will not take this dog tag
necklace off until they come home like
that's not something you can fake and
he's not a faker so no I agree I've at
this present moment no issues with Mr
musk no issues with Mr musk but anyways
you know they're always trying to take
out Mr musk and now this anti-Semitism
thing is being used as like label so
that they can stop advertising with him
also a couple of advertisers their
advertisements had appeared next to um I
didn't I I didn't see it but what
they're saying is like notzi things um
wait what like I don't I don't know
exactly what it was but there was like
advertisers on Twitter their advertisers
like were next
to anti-semitic rhetoric Nazi propaganda
but like isn't that on every platform
right right um anyway so what he said
was he said don't advertise if someone
is going to try and blackmail me with
advertising blackmail me with money go
[__] yourself go [__] yourself is that
clear hey Bob if you're in the audience
that's how Bob Iger Disney cuz they
pulled their ads that's how I feel don't
advertise and then the interviewer is
like but Elon if you don't have
advertisers you don't have a business
what are you going to do um and he said
that if that's what's going to happen
then that's what's going to happen and
the whole earth will know that X went
down because of these advertisers
and that uh he said quote let the chips
fall where they may did he say that he
said it but did he do the hand motion
did he say let the chips fall where they
may no no he didn't and so that he needs
he needs to do better and he said of the
post that sparked the advertiser Exodus
the post I was just telling you about I
should in retrospect not have replied to
that particular post and should have
expanded in Greater length about what I
meant I handed a loaded gun to those who
hate me he added calling it one of the
most foolish things he had said on the
platform yeah I um I'm just like I'm
focused on like on real anti-Semitism
like not this
like it's strategic you know I'm focused
on like people who are really
anti-semitic and like go out and cause
violence and hurtes and say things like
like I'm focused on like real
anti-Semitism and that's I think where
everyone should be from both celebrities
and non-celebrities and there are plenty
of celebrities who are posting the
wildest anti-semitic [__] the lies like
if Bella and Gigi Hadid are not smeared
and canceled for being anti-semitic like
Elon is not even on the list no and I
I'm hesitant to call her a celebrity but
that girl from Fifth Harmony Have You
Seen Her Twitter Lauren yeah you know
when she starts coming out with the you
people I know everything I need to know
and she's deeply unwell and she needs to
get the [__] off the internet now I
would say you know she'll never work in
this town again but she pretty much
already handled that for herself before
Gaza you know she's also so small even
if she were getting canceled I don't
know like the headlines would be so big
but she's not not a famous person like
no she's recognized and I Fifth Harmony
was Global for a moment she's literally
a Hamas fan girly you have to read her
twiter it's insane and there's a there's
a lot of people like that who are you
know operating at that level celebrity
intellectual political journalists like
no cancellations it's like it's it's
open dialogue so Elon so Elon replied to
a tweet that wasn't perfectly quaffed
and felt bad about it clarified and then
took a trip to Israel I'm seriously I'm
not going to lose sleep over this there
are worst things going on no not for one
second but um the big news was pretty
much go [__] yourself hey Bob
hey Bob this is tough for us this is
tough for us because Bob is a a a real
fixture here at the toast he is but he's
more of like it's the idea of Bob you
know no and it's like what does Bob
represent no I literally I don't know
Bob but he's just like the it's the idea
of him he's the head of Disney he was
the head of like the studios against the
sagra like he is a
symbol and he's interchangeable I'm
sorry Bob he literally just lost his
Disney job and got it back like he's
yeah interchangeable it's true
Elon once in a lifetime it's true not
like other businessmen and lob literally
not like other
businessmen so that's the latest
business news are you ready for our
fifth and final story I am like my eye
is twitching and I'm annoyed okay but
it's sports news oh does that get you
perked up it does and it's Aaron Rogers
news I saw him practicing Aaron Rogers
returns to the practice field 11 weeks
after Achilles heel surgery he's eyeing
a December 24th comeback oh my God
Christmas Christmas is coming and so is
Aaron Christmas is coming and so is a
now this could be a smut novel movie too
like where he's like injured he falls in
love with the physical therapist he's
injured and it's the big Christmas game
will he make it and then of course he
makes it they win him and his physical
therapist have Christmas together they
[__] the end yeah and he was had so many
walls up because you know football was
hard no he was angry when he came into
PT and he was like I don't need this I
can do it he tries to stand up on his
own you know that's a classic scene and
he can't she he falls she catches him he
has to accept her
help I love it I love it I love it the
Jets quarterback who tore his Achilles
heel in the season opener in September
made his first appearance on the
practice field with teammates on
Wednesday in a press conference Jets
head coach Robert Salah addressed his
return to practice after news broke that
his 2way 21-day practice window had
started the window expires on December
20th giving the team a three-week period
to decide whether or not to remove
Rogers from the injured reserve should
he be removed he could potentially be on
the field for the December 24 matchup
against the Washington
commanders okay I wish like it was a
more exciting team like like with famous
people on it but I'll take what I can
get okay but also the good news is is
that the Cowboys just beat the
commanders and like the Cowboys aren't
the best team in the NFL so like so the
commanders stink so the Jets have a
chance at winning and and getting a
little
confidence yeah and Aaron looking good
and then going back to his physical
therapist we did
it no this is so crazy he said he was
like I will make a historic comeback I
will be back in December like he didn't
give up on New York and New York
certainly did not go up on him but it's
been a dark couple of weeks with Zach
Wilson at the helm like he's just ill
equipped and I appreciate him stepping
in at a time when we needed him but his
time is definitely up yeah Aaron goes
back to December all the
time there's a song for there's a Taylor
Swift song for every part of Aaron
rogers's Journey no it's true that's why
he's such a Swifty like the morning of
the game against the commanders are you
ready for
it like there's a song and then after he
wins
I mean New Year's Day there's L on the
floor after the party and just wait
until Taylor writes her NL inspired
album for Travis Kelce like oh oh oh
it's over for Aaron it's Aaron coded
100% so I am hoping for a speedy
recovery for Aaron December 24th
hopefully he'll be back on the field I'd
rather see him up there shaking that
thing we're all going to be together for
like the Christmas Day football Shapiro
was at my house he was like so excited
that we were like excited to watch yeah
and it's just going to be a family
affair all the cameras coming out for a
family affair all right all right oh I
had one more thing to say to
you and to everyone which is that I
finished iron flame oh my God I didn't I
finished iron flame and and I think it's
my end of the road for the series it's
it's not the it's not them it's me like
I it was always a little young for me
and a little silly and I it was too much
of my precious time taken up by reading
this book that's how I felt I feel that
but I think like snitch loved it we'll
do a mini recap on the redheads I'm
happy I'm happy for like the fourth wi
family the imperion lives on it was just
too much for me and I have to tap out
yeah I'm like 50% I in days finish it so
it wasn't time wasted yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but I have to start Matthew
Perry's Memoir for my book club so I'm
going to have to take a break from Iron
flame yeah and I'm about to start
Britney it's Britney [__] oh exciting
yeah I'm excited about that so I'm
really happy that I finished the book
because that has just been like every
day I'm like today will be the day and
today was not the day but yesterday was
fabulous thank you we love you know
achieving our goals here at the toast
big or small every goal counts 100% so
that is our show tomorrow is our final
episode of the week so be sure to tune
in then share the toast with somebody in
your life who's miserable and needs
needs us we're doing important work here
it's a hard time of year send the toast
to someone in need you'll be doing them
a favor and Us in in due time so thank
you guys so much for listening to the
toast Morning Show where we deal with
the fast stories to every Monday Friday
and YouTube so watching us on YouTube
please to subscribe and give us video
thumbs up we're also available podcast
podcast Spotify Public Radio cast box
all the places where we listen to
podcast find n the toast five starv
about a beautiful standing and wickedly
talented we
are bye we love you
bye